[Music]
okay hey erica what's up
hi i'm dr johnny how are you
i'm doing all right how are you good
sorry i hung up on you a minute ago
we're still friends right
of course yes
i've i've got a very low number so i
need to preserve all i got so what's up
um
i
need to know
some
other perspective about whether or not i
should
forgive
my husband for
basically cheating on me again
well tell me about it
um
he he had an affair about 10 years ago
and he um
we were able to reconcile it took about
a year and we also had my third child
and
he i told him if he had ever cheated on
me again i would leave him for good and
recently he got fired for sexual
harassment at his job
and what happened
she
told me that
he was being fight that he was being
written up
for sexual harassment because he made a
stupid joke to
somebody that's actually our friend
and she got very angry and so she
um she reported him
and this whole time they weren't nobody
was telling me anything about it and
it lasted about a week
um and so the day that he was fired he
told me that it was for one one joke
and it
was
um
it ended up being more than one joke but
um
that wasn't achieving that he had been
that he had
cheated he had
texted a girl
half his age
um
and talking about
things
inappropriately like wearing her thighs
as your mouth
and um
i miss what you said
she talked about
he was texting this this girl about
um inappropriate things like wearing her
thighs as earmuffs oh okay gotcha gotcha
like just sexually explicit stuff okay
all right i didn't hear what you said
okay
so
wearing her thighs is earmuffs i've nev
i've literally never heard that one
before
um
so
um he gets in trouble at work he's
running his mouth being stupid
and um
you know as well as i do it's rare that
somebody even though with all the
backlash we have these days it's rare
that somebody fires you when it done
right so some some sort of something was
going on there and then as a part of
this you found out the other thing was
going on so what's your what's your big
picture question
um
can i ever trust him again
what do you think you've been living
with him for a decade or more right how
long have you been married
uh two we've been together for 24 years
24 years been married for
19. okay
um you tell me
i don't feel like
i can trust him
i feel like
i i try to believe in people and that
they can change and be better so i feel
like if he was to change
change and grow up
i feel like that would be
i would be able to trust him then but
that's it's those are you're making
those are mutually
those are not mutually exclusive
he can grow up and he can't change
and that doesn't mean you have to be
married to him
he can grow up and he can't change and
he did a couple of times nuke your
marriage
you can choose to stay
and be a part of that healing process
right you see i'm saying there's a bunch
of options and anytime we back ourselves
into a corner and say it's either this
or this we're always going to make a
less than good decision because we feel
forced into a choice and so you've got a
bunch of different options here the
going back to your original question
ultimately forgiveness is for you
and there's some there's a in the
psychology psychological literature
there's some arguments that go back and
forth and in the clinical therapy space
people argue back and forth i'm of the
opinion and again you can get online and
find different opinions and from
brilliant people right
i'm of the opinion that there is little
to no healing without forgiveness
because forgiveness is for you it's not
for him forgiveness is you holding this
brick that he placed in your hands a
brick of infidelity a brick of lack of
trust a brick of dishonesty
and forgiveness is you setting that down
and saying i'm not carrying your stuff
anymore i'm letting this go
now we're going to have to deal with the
consequences of this i can't trust you i
don't want to be with you anymore
um
i
bet
there's a gap of 10 years between this
behavior i have to believe there was
other things that went on right whether
it was all electronic or in person who
knows but it's that it's that gnawing i
don't know what comes next right that
keeps you up at night and you got a
quarter of a century with this person
you all have made humans together right
so there's something to not just throw
away lightly
so i'll circle back to you and this is
the scary question that i'm pretty sure
you have an answer to
what do you want to do
i honestly don't know i feel like if i
if i
work on this healing with him and stay
with him that i'll be disrespecting
myself
and
here's what i think honestly and i've
had this conversation with so many
people over the years i think you know
i think the consequences of your choice
are scary
is that fair yeah
yeah i don't want my children
to have to go through a divorce and i
i was i had
my parents divorced and it they made it
horrible for us and
i don't want to do that to my children
right
and again you've you've put yourself in
an either or there are divorces where
the adults in the room act like adults
and there is separations that say hey
this has to happen because of
so-and-so's behavior but we're going to
treat each other with dignity and
respect for on behalf of these young
kids right so it's not a either
you have to stay miserable and
disrespected in in the hostile
uh situat the home life
or the kids have to go through a messy
divorce it's not either or again okay
it feels like you've made your choice
but the idea of separating moving
getting your own place dividing the
estate all the stuff downstream
is a lot of stuff it's hard that doesn't
mean it's wrong that means it's hard
is there an interim space have you all
spent some time apart
well since he was fired from his job he
had to go
work i told him to go work in another
state and um go work
[Laughter]
he was working in another state before
and then um
and then covet happened and he was home
for that and um
it wasn't as much money but he was
we were struggling but um i told him
that was
seemed to be the only option for him to
be able to
live
so he's he's gone for three to
three plus weeks okay
um
yeah i was gonna say i've heard of
somebody like you gotta go sleep on the
couch i haven't heard somebody be like
you gotta go sleep in missouri or
something i haven't heard that that's a
new one right you gotta go to michigan
um
here's what i think needs to happen two
things number one
um
you've probably heard me say this on the
show i'll say it again because i think
it's worth repeating
when somebody cheats on you
there's the obvious betrayal
and there's the obvious disorientation
like everything we thought we were
standing on the sidewalk that we walk on
now is
busted up right so that that happens
but the i think the a as
if using the sidewalk metaphor you can
fix that sidewalk you can go get a
contractor who will walk alongside
junior can dig all that concrete up and
it stinks and it's hot and all that but
you can get it done you can clean that
up
but i think the silent killer in
infidelity
is
that you erica no longer trust erica
because in your head you think dude i've
been down this road i should have seen
this coming
how in the world oh my gosh how did i
miss this i'm crazy
and if he's good at what he does he'll
say oh it was one time thing i was just
drinking or i was this thing and you're
making a big deal about it and you start
to feel that you're crazy
and you start to feel that you can't
trust you
and that's when you call a guy just a
rando dude on a podcast and you're like
hey i don't even know how to i don't
even know how to feel
you see what i'm saying
and so one of the important parts of
healing from infidelity and this is you
get fired from a job that you're that
you didn't see coming right or a leader
demotes you or gives you a pay cut that
you don't see coming right these are any
type of relational interactions that are
out of the blue and that fracture the
relationship
is you've got to sit down and heal i've
got to learn to retrust myself and just
because this happened doesn't mean i'm
not trustworthy
i'm going to always look in the mirror
and say did i contribute anything in
this in this relationship am i going to
participate i know that's not pc to say
you know did i participate in this have
i what role did i play here and then i'm
gonna be honest with a counselor with a
group of close friends
walking through
i am trustworthy and here's what i think
the next right step is
and so one i think you need to go talk
to a counselor
by yourself and say this is what
happened because my guess is over the
last two decades together
in between the two instances of
infidelity there's been some significant
distance between the two of you is that
fair
um
but yeah every time we've had ever we've
ever had any issues or i felt like we
were
um
in danger
i we've gone and seen counselors or
and if that didn't work i was trying to
work on myself and okay
so you've put the time and the effort in
and it's it's a you're looking at this
as though you failed you screwed
something up
and
i need you to hear me say you didn't
fail okay
three
do you believe me
yes
okay i need you to internalize that you
didn't
fail and if this ends up in divorce
you have options so that it doesn't turn
into a mess that you experienced as a
kid
is it going to hurt your children 100
absolutely is it going to be a mess yes
it's going to be hard yes all those
things are true
um but that doesn't mean it's not the
right thing and
choosing to go get back up on the horse
again and go through the healing process
again and what is this gonna look like
that's not the
necessarily the wrong choice either
i'm afraid that if i do that
that he'll do it again i mean i think
all the evidence suggests that's the
case
right
but i'm not gonna sit here on the phone
after talking to you for five minutes
and say you gotta get out of this
relationship i think it's a mess
i definitely think it's a mess
um tell me about your friend
that you said your husband told a dirty
joke to somebody or dirty jokes to
somebody who happened to be a friend who
told on him and ultimately led to his
departure are you all still talking
apparently um she wants she says that
she just needed a
safe space to work and i feel like
she could it's i feel like she could
have come in outside of work and told me
what was going on and i would have
we could have handled it that way versus
causing a financial
heart ship on our family in addition to
the so hear me say that
i i think she did the right thing
and the person who caused the financial
hardship issues in your home is your
husband not her
now
i would expect my friend to come tell me
right so i get that
the like the
the
schoolyard code i get that totally
but it's your husband that put another
woman in an uncomfortable position at
work
and
based on what you've told me i don't
trust that there was one dirty joke that
was told that ultimately led to him
getting fired
my guess is there's a pattern of
behavior there
right right and so
her repeatedly having to go to work and
be uncomfortable next to her best
friend's cheating husband who also is
making sexual jokes which often sexual
jokes are fishing expeditions
because if she laughs or she winks or
she tells a funny sexual joke back
now we have this connection and now
right see i'm saying so it can go down a
road
and
her saying i feel uncomfortable
um or if she never anyway all i had to
say is
you're gonna have to have this is the
second thing you gotta have some adult
conversations
you gotta sit down with him and say
what's the future i need six months by
myself to be separated or i've lost
trust in you um
at this point i don't feel comfortable
being married to you
or i'm willing to try this thing again
like you all need to get in a room and
go to breakfast somewhere and have some
hard conversations directly across the
table
okay
just saying you go away it's not gonna
help and having these conversations at
home in the context of being at home is
gonna be
hard because it's that that your home is
charged and the kids are right there in
the next room so get out of the house
y'all go sit somewhere and tell them
we're gonna have a hard adult
conversation
and tell them i don't know that i can be
married to you anymore
but also i remember what happened to me
and so if we go down this road of
divorce we're gonna have to be adults on
behalf of these kids
and is that pie in this guy thinking on
my part it might be i just have this
belief that adults can be adults even
when it's hard and i know that there's
millions of people that act like
children all the time it's annoying
um
but all the way back to your original
question forgiveness is for you
and so maybe this breakfast that you'll
go to this lunch or dinner y'all go to
you start that by sit by write that down
put it on a brick put a piece of tape on
a brick and write down
cheating
or you cheated and
put that on the table and hand it to
them and say i'm not carrying this
anymore i forgive you
now here's how i feel and here's some of
the consequences of what happened and
we're going to move forward that way
forgiveness doesn't mean passivity
forgiveness doesn't mean consequences
forgiveness doesn't mean i forget
everything forgiveness just means i'm
not carrying this and that's for you
not for him
don't carry that around um but do go see
somebody you got some healing work to do
and you need some help sifting through
the jungle of your feelings and thoughts
right now because it's a lot
and
last thing i'll tell you i'll remind you
it's not your fault
it's not your fault